porque con nuestro segundo invitado del
día vamos a hablar de qué son los
pensamientos intrusivos y cuando se
convierten entonces en un problema estos
pensamientos intrusivos son los que
aparecen en nuestra mente por ejemplo
por si solos o por una situación en la
que nos encontramos lo reconocemos para
luego simplemente hacerlo a un lado
hacerlo de un lado y poder seguir
adelante pero para algunas personas en
ciertos momentos de la vida puedes
descartar estos pensamientos intrusivos
puede volverse más difícil y puede
volverse incluso un problema quiero
saludar entonces a nuestro segundo
invitado pablorromeros anti psicólogo
clínico investigador y profesor de la
universidad rockhampton en londres
gracias a pablo por estar con nosotros
esta mañana en directo américa de france
24 le pregunto realmente qué son estos
pensamientos intrusivos
lo primero muchas gracias por invitarme
encantado de estar con vosotros en los
pensamientos intrusivos creo que lo has
definido muy bien los pensamientos
intrusivos son intrusos en nuestra mente
aparecen por sorpresa están un poco
fuera de nuestro control pueden tomar
diferentes formas desde imágenes como
fotos rápidas que aparecen en nuestra
mente es simplemente una especie de
monólogo que tenemos con nosotros mismos
cosas que nos decimos a nosotros mismos
pero eso que están fuera de nuestro
control de nuestro control nos resultan
extraños en el caso de los que son
problemáticos o patológicos nos sentimos
muy muy asustados o muy ansiosos cuando
tenemos ese tipo de pensamiento pero
pensamientos intrusivos normales existen
y los tenemos todos es le quería
preguntar qué tan normal son estos
pensamientos intrusivos y digamos cuál
es el origen
bien lo tenemos todos los tenemos todos
es un tipo de pensamiento muy normal
creo que si pongo un par de ejemplos
creo que la gente se reconocerá en estos
ejemplos cuando estamos saliendo de casa
y decimos ay he dejado un puesto a la
plancha la hornilla la deja la podría
dejar puesta encerrado el coche este
tipo de pensamientos los podemos tener
todos es esa especie de duda que tenemos
es perfectamente normal ahora bien
cuando se escapan de nuestro control
cuando evaluamos esos pensamientos y nos
sentimos más mal por tener por tenerlos
por ejemplo si en vez de me he dejado
las llaves es y si le ha pasado algo a
mi hijo y no me dado cuenta la angustia
es mucho mayor y puede la gente puede
quedarse enganchada en esos pensamientos
y en conductas de comprobación para ver
si eso que estás que he pensado es
realidad o no claro -pablo incluso ahí
hay otro tipo de pensamientos intrusivos
está lloviendo yo un artículo para esta
conversación de la bbc de londres que
decía que un pensamiento intrusivo por
ejemplo podría ser si estoy cortando el
pan y de repente me volteo y le hago
daño a la persona que está al lado
también caería o se acabe en la
normalidad de estos pensamientos
intrusivos o ahí es cuando uno empieza a
evaluar o identificar si podemos tener
algún problema algún tipo de patología
claro ese tipo de pensamientos depende
si los pensamientos empiezan a ser un
poquito más extraños o si los
pensamientos se empiezan a ser un
poquito más amenazantes como el ejemplo
que he puesto que he puesto antes el
ejemplo que ha puesto tú es muy bueno
esa madre que sale de acostar a su hijo
y de pronto se le pasa por la cabeza y
está este tipo de pensamiento lo tiene
la gente y si lo he ahogado sin darme
cuenta entonces con muchísima angustia
tiene que ir a volver a comprobar si el
niño está bien cuando está esa persona
tiene ese tipo de pensamiento se
pregunta a sí misma por qué tengo este
pensamiento porque me pasa a mí esto es
normal y mucha gente llega a pensar y si
resulta que quiero hacerle daño a mi
hijo de una manera inconsciente y yo no
lo sé ahí es cuando ya estamos en un
problema ahí es cuando hay que consultar
con un profesional con un psicólogo un
psiquiatra para ver si podemos tener un
diagnóstico de trastorno obsesivo
compulsivo
afortunadamente hay tratamientos que
funcionan bastante bien
es le quería preguntar antes de avanzar
a ese tema cuál es la diferencia de un
pensamiento intrusivo digamos
completamente normal en cualquier ser
humano o si tenemos algún tipo de toque
bien hay dos tipos de diferencias la
diferencia de contenido es un poco más
dudosa ya digo si el contenido es
relativamente normal de la vida diaria
como si me dejado las llaves si no sigue
cerrado bien el coche o no eso es algo
normal que nos pasa a todos no hay que
preocuparse si el contenido empieza a
ser un poquito más complicado como lo he
dicho de ysl hecho el daño a mi hijo o
por ejemplo por ejemplo y si me he dado
la vuelta he matado a alguien y no me
dado cuenta cuando uno empieza a tener
ese tipo de pensamientos eso puede ser
un poquito puede ser más complicado pero
luego aparte del contenido el proceso
que hacemos evaluando el pensamiento es
clave si te sientes completamente
responsable de lo que pudiera pasar por
tener ese pensamiento si piensas que
tiene que comprobar para ver si lo has
hecho o no ahí también estaríamos
entrando en la patología porque el
pensamiento toma el control de tu vida
toma completamente control sobre tus
actos sobre tus pensamientos si no
puedes pensar en otra cosa que no sea
ese pensamiento que hacer digamos en un
escenario de una persona sin ningún tipo
de patologías para que estos
pensamientos digamos estén controlados
para que no tome el control de nosotros
y nos sigamos dándole vueltas a la
cabeza digamos en este mismo pensamiento
que muchas veces seguramente nos pasa si
vamos a ver cuando somos cuando no
tienes una patología cuando no tienes un
top en la mayoría de los casos el
pensamiento se va cuando no tienes una
patología y no se te va puede ser porque
tienes mucho estrés porque estás en un
momento de tu vida con muchas muchas
preocupaciones y entonces ese nivel de
ansiedad hace que ese pensamiento un
poquito te invada algo más y yo siempre
utilizo diferentes estrategias con
pacientes que pueden no tener top pero
sí este tipo de problema y es intentar
hacer las cosas que me provocan esos
pensamientos como por ejemplo cerrar la
puerta de casa o desenchufar la plancha
de una manera más lenta más pausada para
así a acordarse bien de haber hecho esas
cosas eso estamos hablando de gente sin
trastorno obsesivo compulsivo
trastorno obsesivo compulsivo es otra
cosa muy diferente podemos digamos
acabar con estos pensamientos intrusivos
de nuestra conversación al que nos quede
de vida o es imposible
no no por supuesto se pueden acabar con
se puede acabar con los pensamientos
incluso si tienes trastorno obsesivo
compulsivo tenemos tratamientos
psicológicos terapia
cognitivo-conductual exposición y
prevención de respuestas son
tratamientos que funcionan muy bien muy
muy eficaces con lo cual yo si hay
alguien que nos está viendo que tiene
este tipo de problema recomendaría que
sin miedo consultar con un profesional
es algo de lo que es algo que se puede
tratar es algo de lo que se puede salir
y hay que ir a por ello hay que hay que
enfrentarlos y hay que hay que realizar
el tratamiento que no es fácil pero
funciona y por favor como siempre
ponerle la lupa a nuestra salud mental
no es un tabú hay que hablarlo y pues
hay que acudir por supuesto al
especialista en el momento que pues nos
sintamos que algo pasa y pues para un
diagnóstico obviamente individualizado y
con un especialista